we will start with our caller from the
six four seven area code caller from six
four seven tell us who you are and good
go right ahead David my name is John I'm
just here looking at your video on why
I'm not a socialist so I'll start by
saying I don't agree with you I don't
agree with socialism I don't agree with
democratic socialism or social democracy
the systems that you like to push on to
your show so hold on a second if I if I
may John let's I just want to make sure
I understand you so that when you get to
your question we're on the same page you
so that was a video where I explained
why I support social democracy but I'm
not a socialist or some of the other
things you mentioned you said you just
don't agree with any of those things but
I I and you said that I pushed those
things but I don't I don't push all
those things the video was about why I'm
not a socialist right I want to make
sure you understood the video no I
understood your you're trying to make a
distinction between Venezuelan socialism
North Korean socialism USSR socialism as
being authoritarian whereas you prefer
or like the system such as Sweden you do
mention Sweden in particular in the
video where it's by you switch between
the labels of social democracy and
what's the one that Bernie Sanders uses
uh what's the other one
that Ocasio Court has uses like no
social democracy better no democratic
socialism democratic village
yeah that's social is it but so John I
just want to make sure you I don't I
don't switch between calling something
social democracy or democratic socialism
I'm pointing out that that one of them
is socialism and one of them is not like
Sweden is not a socialist country do we
do we agree on that and what they're
that Sweden doesn't have a socialist
system where by all means of production
are our publicly owned like Sweden's
Sweden's a capitalist country and they
have a strong social welfare and safety
net right so it's not it's just not a
socialist country do you agree with that
in the strictest sense of the word
socialism yes it is not a socialist
country yeah okay good all right all
right go ahead
so basically my might beep what that is
um I don't know if you've ever studied
economics extensively you'll know that
it you know it's a stagnating system
compared to a capitalist pure capitalist
system versus one where people's
property and income is expropriated by
the state and redistributed into things
like social programs to elaborate you
know social engineering schemes and
other things of the sort whatever the
winds of the leader or party in question
is so what would be an example of that
like what can you give me an example of
a place that's seizing people's property
to conduct social engineering like what
would be an example of that I think they
seizing property I said expropriating
their property in the forms of Taxation
ok we'll give you what's an example of
the social engineering that's being done
well one thing I was actually looking up
recently it was you know how Bernie on
the sand Bernie Sanders on the campaign
trail kept citing of Sweden and
democratic socialist countries and
Scandinavia
he kept citing Sweden and I was looking
up and some of these things that
Sweden's been doing and Oh a couple
years ago
Sweden's finance minister anders Borg
came out and he cited how in the 1980s I
think you're familiar with this you
might have talked about it before
they imposed a sort of Wall Street
speculation tax which is what Bernie was
proposing here in Sweden and they kicked
that off in the 1980s in order to fund
some things that the party wanted to get
done and there was this sort of an air
of why are these people making more
money and why are we not making more
money we because a little Eric and we're
why do they have to have more than we
have so they tax the tax the called
finance or transactions and in their in
their finance jean are you saying that
that a government it using taxes to pay
for things as social engineering or are
you saying that a government using taxes
to pay for things at socialism because
it's neither but I'm curious which one
you're claiming it is well personally I
I dare on the side of libertarianism but
I
see some uses for the state although no
but John what what I'm asking you is the
following I asked you for an example of
social engineering
you said Sweden in the 80s had a tax and
the money raised was used to pay for
stuff is that what you're saying is an
example of social engineering it is yeah
what else would it be
okay all right John thank you for the
call
I appreciate it I don't know what you're
talking about but but I do appreciate
you taking the time to call in okay
let's I just don't know I did I do I
mean it was I misunderstanding there I
just I don't know how taxing and and
that's how a government that's just
called government that's yeah Ashland
I'm sure he's in favor of at least a few
social services I know he said he's a
libertarian but as you want roads is
that social and roads and fire
department and Police Department
you're psychologically encouraging
people to use to travel if you put in
roads that's social engineering I guess
I don't know